it was sup welcome to pax 2014 penny
arcade expo right here from Seattle is
the first time I've been here I've done
pax east twice but I've never ever been
here and it looks crazy so we're gonna
go walk the show floor I've literally
never even been on the show for yet but
first we're here in Sector G this is
gamespot and John bombs wonderful bar of
sorts for people to hang out and video
games Brandi did go around like a crazy
person on the Steadicam this is the
stage giant bomb folks could be doing a
premium show later on tonight but like I
said I've never been to show floor so
Andy let's experience it together users
apparently it's really packed so I I've
been out of rubbing shoulders we can fit
it's kind of hyperlapse all this okay
look the thing about the thing about pax
is you keep you keep bumping into people
you know how you doing Danny what's up
ty rude I just randomly walked across
the street and saw you here it's good
that's the wonder of packs and I can't
wait to see who else we bump into while
we wander I don't know anybody here
we're not gonna see anybody no one goes
to show that's a lie that's a lie sup
Mario ah he was street passing
I still need to get a lanyard we still
have the thing and for some reason the
price ones have PAX East information on
the back of them but I'm hoping they
don't think I made this one mom and
snooze you lose
come come come to pax come don't worry
don't look left or right or anything
Andy it's fine all right here we go
people in cosplay already I feel like a
jerk for wearing normal clothes all
right up one more all right one more one
more again pax apparently is on the roof
all right we could just stop the video
here it could be a tour of all the
elevators in Seattle Recari some video
games here we go my god oh here we go
yeah not here we are here all this
lanyards they got lanyards everything I
love it exactly the same as proxies
behemoth booth first thing you see when
you walk in redonkulous but I put this
thing on well it's official all right
let's go look at some packs behemoth
once again the gift shop is their like
biggest pole
telltale over here this is way tighter
than pax east it's in like one big
convention center this is just his skull
candy Park City represent Andy back here
you like that any oh man lightstone
bakla my house I wonder if our boy
Michael macmaine is in there they got a
big-ass booth they got her whoa
so according to Michael they were trying
to get a booth for the past while
everyone like locks down their boots
whenever anyone has one they got first
refusal the next year I'm like a month
ago somebody decided to pull out so they
had to get this one it's like one of the
biggest boots in the whole bloody place
what's going on here oh man wanna play
mrs. pepper
he's got a feeling you guys
the best way to play the crew so as ever
boots full of proprietary hardware stuff
can get yourself involved in some desert
island or dead island MOBAs play with
these in booth don't start with one of
those games are really fits in packs
pretty good pics small downloadable
games seem to get a lot more space here
than they would some rest Jesus Christ
sup sir what is this thankful oh man has
pitching thanks sir congratulation
outstanding outstanding shame he scared
the crap out of its own weight was he
cosplaying as a Titan then was I Wow oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I was wondering where this
was
if you want any sort of a visual
representation of how big league of
legends is then this is it right here
this is like almost the size of the rest
of the hall north american championships
look it is hi I love that that's just
happening in like a side room it's like
all these video games having in here and
then to the side the frickin North
American finals for League of Legends
participial t-shirts part just simple
hats look at I had that's a video game
hat right there I've seen loads people
with these portland's ones and then
these other ones we've got black mesa
ones because the logos are almost
identical oh ah picture right there Oh
wargaming we got wargaming look at all
these people
run some scam bleak I've street fighter
art because we got plenty of it here
take a bit
crimson viper sitting down with a wry
phone
oh man is that a massive Pikachu I think
there's a massive inflatable Pikachu
pokemons art academy on the DA sadly
there are none of those new and sunny
one of those new ds's air packs
apparently Nintendo in Japan decided to
just release that what I think it sent
over America in in on it here's twitches
Pilatus nonsense twitch other live
stream light show for a couple of days
here wonderful boy carnage is here of
course they crashed out of the games
journalism Hunger Games earlier today it
was so much a boy Justin play and they
do my friend Manny oh my God we're doing
it how are you doing Evie oh yeah have
you gotten over the defeat at the game
journalism hunger games over today yeah
i'm pretty sure i got over accounting
all my money in the back there I saw her
cookbook hi wait you doing two bucks why
is actually hosting just a minute ago
got a place no mortal kombat x otherwise
just enjoying some pokemon or street
fighter and whatever
you gotta go look at something right now
yeah i think when actually poker to the
pokemon booth again my boy John hey
doing the math here to somebody good to
see you hello yes it's great to be here
Kenya dwyer one of my heroes I just want
to say hormad egg and John women when is
the rebranding happening then uh you
don't see you have to look deep without
your heart what's it like what's the
mood around the twitch world at the
moment like a name in light of the news
of the Amazon acquisition oh you know
you guys are questioning Amazon's ago
all four days ago and so it's still it's
still coming it's still happening right
so we're still seeping in you're
sweating why all right I'm sweater
asking me these hard questions and
you're the one button what's going on
man it's good man everybody's happy I
know no more hot questions it's packs
enjoy the show we're gonna keep we're
gonna keep walking man pleasures ever
sir let's keep walking let's keep see
what else you can find it that's a packs
all the back just bumping into your
buddies internet buddies you've never
seen before it's ridiculous you keep
seeing familiar faces around the place
oh you're not quite sure if they're
people you actually know or if they're
just like internet people you know oh
there's a whole lot of all over here
it's like a whole lot of home
I'm gonna stick to selling furniture oh
man it's like ultimate dnd furniture
zombicide look at this stuff ranging
from nineteen hundred dollars
thirty-four hundred dollars it's pretty
cool comes here once again they track
the nasty drippy mouth goo model they
have it pax east all the way out here
everything is esports now there's chef
casters for every game these guys
yo look at this dude some sick ass
cosplay some of the effort it gets put
into this like not even in terms of like
just doing it up like in terms of like
physical sculpting to be able to make
yourself look like an orc sorry dude if
you have a friend you're coming to packs
with make them carry a hammer it's the
only way to not lose each other let's do
it look at that oh my gosh it's
terrifying these costumes took a really
seriously I love it shadows of Mordor
here Andy baman adjusted hey Walt saw
that bad boy see there preview on
gamespot com what's going on we got
battle cry over here no more check us
this guy
what's going on we can double we can
double up on microphones sword fight hey
don't doing well how about you not too
bad your name by any chance my name is
Ian Sam I my boytoy root says here
you're a yeah yeah says you're the man
to talk to you about grunt it is true I
am I guess the man to talk to about
battle cry at this moment here let me
take off there we go why no jacket oh
he's got to get his face on gotta get my
media face on I was at it what's the
brand name brand name is of course
battle cry the game brought to you by
battle cry the studio hailing from
Austin Texas Austin Texas of course the
previous home of Thai roots some of you
be it be no stranger to Thai bird anyway
you probably want to know a little about
this game I left a little bit of a
papaya all right I'll try and sum it up
very succinctly so battle cry is a team
action combat game featuring three soon
to be five unique character classes yeah
we have melee classes branched classes
classes that defy categorization you do
two jobs at once it works perfectly
we also have two unique factions soon to
be three will be making some really big
announcements at pax Australia in just
two months from now so if you guys want
to stay tuned and find out more about
that you can either go to Sydney or you
can sign up at our website battlecry the
game.com when it'll be available for
people to play right now in their homes
so we'll be coming up with our beta
program sometime in 2015 if you want an
early look into that beta again battle
cry the game calm and click on the
enlist now button in the bottom right
corner of the screen I'm exhausted Ian
thank you very much your time thank you
do you work out man you're so you're so
we're so small right now do you even
lift bro I feel like the [ __ ] lettuce
and a muscle sandwich I need to get out
of here thank you very much you
appreciate it where we going magic 2015
blue is the bit where I'm be speeds it
all up and makes it go real fast
oh man look at this ladies it's a new
team meet game making I don't want to
say to making super me point an endless
runner because it's not but it is a
automatic I am running iOS version of
super meat boy and my looks at this
gameplay as bloody difficult oh is it
procedurally generated oh I like this
let's have a look let's have a closer
look manly the sizes tablet was the best
way to show this game off you two can
play super meat boy forever on your
massive tablet home sometime in the
future oh minus video he's got a good
run going on here I have a 100
percentage super meat boy so this is one
of the few games of them perhaps looking
forward to playing on my mobile device
sometime soon no sign of mr. McMillan
here so we'll keep on moving Yeah right
he must be here somewhere I'm sure he is
oh yeah here we go mega booth in the
mega boots right here boom center right
there big eyes purple sign in the
distance we're gonna bunch of coverage
of this up on gamespot com lovers in a
dangerous space time is over there
played on Germany let's have a little
freezer in here oh man
+ + + is here and plus buses here I
don't care about editing outs and plus
buses here oh my god
the sequel years in the making M plus
plus coming soon to PlayStation 4 i
believe this is an exclusive this is one
of biggest games on xbox 360 back in two
thousand eight the same might be 2007
it's pretty dope I love that game so
hard once we got hotline Miami 2 is
right here play your boat check it out
you know make us out here sup dudes all
right hey do and you guys made this
video game right hey dude what's up it's
good i need wire from gamespot pleasure
to meet you sir it is yeah good have you
guys had this playable at any
conferences so far around the world yeah
yeah we had a deal in word games calm
and we were
all the pax's i learned there it's like
my first one this year sorry pretty
pretty you were okay so you're not that
tired you didn't just come over from
Germany then not too bad yeah I did what
I was enough gamescom I see no pork
knuckle now I had to work ok that's a
shame yeah well how far you guys away
from the launch at this stage not hard
but I can't tell you when ok and what's
it like evident people's hands again
obviously last time you guys you're
shopping around hello man I'm why Miami
people didn't really ignore it was of
course now there's a sort of an
expectation or some sort of
understanding what it is what's it like
getting feedback from people on a wrong
number it's great I mean a lot easier to
sell the game this time around that's
the first one you know I mean hotline
Miami isn't fun to watch or you'll see a
screenshot you have to play it so now
that people know what it is it's easier
to like grab them in and also seeing
that people liked it so much give us a
lot of confidence that people get the
first one we made it because we couldn't
buy it ourselves so it's cool to see
that so many people want to buy games
like this sweet so coming out soon
soonish yeah soon as possible ok enjoy
the rest of box make sure what you're
talking to us sweets that's one of the
cool things about pack so you can just
kind of wander up and meet the dude who
made the game you loved under so many of
them here let me start fighter darknet
hey what's up hey you doing good
aleksandar Bruce critter bounty chamber
what's going on right now I'm talk sorry
interrupt your conversation and not go
over each other how you doing my friend
I am fantastic how are you great are you
still evangelizing indie games that you
weren't involved in creating
absolutely all the time that's why I
follow the mega booth around then please
by all means tell us your favorite pics
another mega blew through this year it's
too early in the show from you do that
so you'll have to come back in a couple
of days should get you on this so we
should get you on the show some sage
over the next couple days you got a busy
schedule no not at all I have no
schedule okay all right let's talk oh
sorry nice talk to you keep-keep
perusing I let us know right this goes
until Monday sure maybe come back on
Monday okay okay cool thanks Alexander
that's great dude lives in Australia
he's over here half the time though he's
great last jetpacks Prime he gave me
like he's good at picking at games you
wouldn't necessarily have a look at
Magic Circle oh man we got kind of roll
over here I've sunk at least like 60
hours it's [ __ ] all over the past month
or so Teresa how are you how we doing at
the moment encounter brawl are you
getting your ass kicked live again and
I'm playing with one of our best players
that I could mention so far so it's a
it's a lot of fun and it's a good it's
an honor to play with him actually you
guys are like a lot of weeks away from
release at this stage it's September
19th it's actually really seared it's
kind of crazy what's a like a minute
here in people's hands again presumably
the last you know you've you've gotten a
lot more people playing it over the past
couple of months and weeks okay um it's
actually really cool because even though
we've been in early access its I've had
to really let go and just be okay with
seeing a lot of things that weren't
finished in people's hands I know the
game is so far has come along so far
that I'm actually pretty proud of it now
it just is a good feeling cool all right
we'll get you on the lobby couple of
weeks yeah perfect okay past the lock
this game is friggin brilliant i played
this in PAX East order to see your
Galaxy I think your brain is doing some
sort of feature on it procedurally the
generator world's really kind of sick
combat or great manga saw graphics it
looks absolutely brave I cannot wait to
finally get my hands on that bad boy
it's weird like a lot of the games you
see here that have been shown all over
the place various boxes it's so like
people talk about III and how cool III
is to attend like III is nothing on
parks III you cue up and you play a
canned demo for you know ten minutes and
then they kick you out again at PAX you
get to talk to the developer probably
talk to a bunch of other fans of the
game as well fairway solitaire blast yes
game of show there's some people in what
looks oh man they're playing oculus in
little sitting rooms oh [ __ ] super hot
how far that game has come machinima are
showing he holds a teenage dream in
Charles movie I'm not really sure pet
the legality of that pie shell went up
it's probably better than that new one
alright freaking out galaxies in here as
well chasm spelunky Tomic shay will be
happy with that blood-borne they got
blood bond playable here looks like and
I missed this when I was at Gamescom
this is blood-borne the from software
joined all you Dark Souls fans and here
is the xbox boot this is not a great
thing about epoxy comparison to III is
that like the biggest boots at e3 are
microsoft sony a lot of hardware stuff
here it's you know mega boots probably
about the same size as xbox
sunset overdrive we got them on the
stage on a sec 2 g's stage orion
applying for us or in the blind forest
is this is a game that I was pretty
apathetic about after seeing it at e3 I
finally got my hands on the gamescom and
is absolutely fantastic it looks really
pretty and I was kind of worried that
they may rest on that a bit too much and
gable they might be boring it's
fantastic so if you're ever at a
convention or if you're here at the
moment and you watching this in your
hotel room check out our way in the
Black Forest what the hell is it what
that's got here the friggin listen
there's an elephant fighting a snow
leopards all right take him back Sue's
winning I'm putting five on elephant
kick his arse out of fun what do you
thinks gonna win I'm gonna go at the
elephant up in ya guys go on he's got
the size good point he's also got tusks
come on out of foot yes don't be careful
video games 2014
look at that form I just realized this
is a far cry 4 thing I didn't even get
up a word
finish your ball hey go video games 2014
so do until Thursday covering packs
splits more boxes go do it sup it's your
name Taylor pleasure to meet you sir
good to meet you enjoying packs yes I am
indeed what are you seeing on packs at
the moment what is the best thing you've
seen at the pack so far oh man I don't
know just a lot of that stuff in the
indie mega boobs really cool Taylor
spend all the time inside of the indie
mega booth what was the one game you
like the most negative for the hotline
Miami 2 wrong number oh that one's
pretty good i like galaxy a lot oh so
good we're talking about that is the
best yeah it's pretty cool yeah you're
gonna exhume nails you want to get all
your checklist you haven't seen you oh
man there's just there's a lot of stuff
I don't even know where to begin to get
a tasty sandwich maybe go to the
bathroom I might be not justice yeah
some of that yeah calories salaries
there yeah I can tell you do a thing
about putting on calories Taylor alright
thanks for checking i'm on Joe dressier
packs mmm smells like Rubens in here mmm
you guys eating Reuben Oh hot dogs in
delicious take it back unbelievable yeah
this is the [ __ ] guy smells like
subway pretty sure it's subway are we
going upstairs for going up stairs over
here parnis there's a sixth floor
here we are here we go I've been saga so
it seems to be a sort of a group of
either D&D tabletop games maybe some
special interest video game groups it's
pretty cool console freeplay check out
what's going on here poke our heads in
to see what hell's going on people
playing mario party some titanfall get
two can I ask you a question what's
going on what's gone was your name your
name dude boat man boat man great name
what the hell's going on here what is
this room console freeplay what happens
to be picture to play whatever games
they want you have to go up in rent a
game we have plenty of systems we have
games around we have controllers up
there yeah all you do is go up and take
a number waiting in line for them to
call you and you rent whatever you want
well how much how much does it cost to
rent like say nothing nope totally free
yes oh man thank you very much your time
appreciate it hey go just come use video
game you won easy peasy lemon squeezy
just don't steal oh my guys anything
somebody date somebody I wanted a rice
son of Rome just left it there yeah I
get it hege pole shake your button on
your hands you play that game what your
but I play this game with your but you
don't play with your butt but when you
can't but gets hit in the game in real
time you get a rumble in your
it's on green lighting so we need help
we need your votes and we need your bar
if you like barfing eating balls and
having your butt wiggle the bed get on
greenlight pick Ebola look up piggy ball
thanks guys make sure how much plane are
let me play appreciate it nothing says
packs like you tailor kilts what's up
hey doing buddy what's your name my name
is Paul vigors Paul you tailor kills
packs they are almost almost like
brothers how many tickets have you sold
since y'all since packs opened today I
think I actually haven't counted but I
in a guess right off the top and had
about 20 20 yeah yeah I think so how
much how much money's brought by gonna
cost the Workmen's runs to 60
cheers and I've had I've had mine for
eight and a half years I mean yeah it's
definitely been through the ringer I'm
so wearing it I mean it's definitely
definitely looks a little worn in but
it's still still serving me well after
all awesome dude thank you so much best
of luck some till Achilles right here at
pax appreciate it look at his bison
because you can buy clothes here as well
can play games and make your ass shaking
to buy clothes to ask them shake them
more costume Christ right over here as
well oh man Patrick laughing god dammit
god dammit he changed you don't smell
anymore i did i do I smell like I just
cuz I was over at the utilikilt booth so
I just missed power one in what are you
doing I just in perusing seeing stuff
what's what is going on up here is it
just like overflow from the indie mega
booth or something got midnight city
devolver it is basically just like an
indie haven over here you have a video
ball stuff I have you seen much of
Pakistan owed sunny day one you've been
walking around all day the best thing I
saw the first thing we did was
announcing this like camera to show I
don't know what the full name of the
game it's called keep talking
it's an oculus game one person puts on
the RHIB all we know this there's a bomb
and if you don't know how to defuse it
the other people around you have access
to a manual that they flip through and
they tell you how to defuse the bomb so
like you got the rip down you're going
like there's six wires do for blue and
then they look through the man you'll
find the wire page it's like oh the
second wire is blue then cut the fourth
wire and I Jeff took immediate control
the situation he's scribbling down like
english notes and like dan records like
trying to solve the bomb we saw that
bomb then i put it on we didn't solve
the bob luckey that was the best thing I
saw sweet yeah yeah I'm gonna keep on
looking yeah huh huh is it is it is this
really a job what is what it's like what
is video games I don't know thanks very
much Patrick got some who ya sorry kid
almost knocked down a child he's on his
mom is screaming at him this guy knows
how to sell i got that video game video
bought of school reminds me of a Tokra
bit from air sports friends well I check
in on that pipe or later we're doing I a
load of much more deeper coverage not
just one [ __ ] Irishman walking
through the boots spinning around in
circles hey yeah that's what's up sup
Doug sup buddy what's your name Damian
Damian pleasure to meet you sir you
enjoin packs yes enjoy what's it what's
the favorite game you've seen help here
on this crazy 64 of madness on the sixth
floor of my fear every game
or anywhere anywhere anywhere it's
definitely warlords of draenor oh yeah
yeah warlords of Draenor Wow four
straight over to the blizzy booth yeah I
had to get my my beta keys so I'm really
get back home now where's the bait open
November 13 oh that's like the week of
this con I think yes yes you gotta go
tube is gone I wish I can't afford it
kind of that you spent all your money
going to pack pack it did hey coming
here good choice yeah hey thanks guys
not at all alright fledged image nice
nice to meet you oh my god this thing
just keeps going look at this stuff it's
all over here mega64 got their booth
over here okay I got the best ice bucket
challenge in a lot great ice bucket
challenge good job roosterteeth got
their store that's why I love about it
as well you got all these like crazy
popular video game websites and they
kind of make a little bit of a showing
at e3 but it's not the same thing
because III is just full of Industry
people frame is a great game I played at
a taxi started in here for iOS like when
we're covering games on gamespot like so
much of it like seventy percent of it is
games it you guys already know about we
already know about big retail games to
pick publishers they send this press
releases take the information to send
this review code all that sort of stuff
but then like the most interesting part
of job probably is like meeting people
who are making these obscure games that
don't have marketing spans that don't
reach out to video game websites and
like trying to pick up on those by
poison and chopping them and expose them
like lovely planet for instance here
that's gay we're gonna have an alarming
mix of leaf salt on giant bomb and this
whole area is it's basically just that
it's just stuff that you probably would
never hear a bed or wouldn't Mike cross
paths but on the Internet so I'm gonna
turn off the camera now and he's gonna
go to the bow story spend all this money
ahead of crap ups and I'm gonna go play
some indie games so thanks so much for
walking around pax enjoying I enjoyed my
first packs show floor experience here
in Seattle with you folks I don't forget
we are continuing coverage on gamespot
com including much deeper coverage of a
lot of the games you might have just
seen a little pinch pink golf today
alright go play some games adios top
story
you